[Music]
across the Pacific Ocean to Central
America to one of the charm fish and
capitals of the world Costa Rica
it's very scary when you think about
hole dominated Asian market fishing as
far as here to supply this huge network
industry off the shark fin
I suppose the big question for me is can
I actually get on one of these [ __ ]
boats and go shark fishing to see what
exactly they're up to and how big a
scale it is for the last 20 years
Taiwanese fishing fleets have plundered
the shark rich waters here and now this
small country is one of the biggest
exporters of fins in the world marine
biologist Randal aru's has spent years
taking on the might of the shark fishing
industry this is the place where it all
gets organized yeah
what's gonna happen now in the next five
years with these waters to the extent of
what they're fishing well at least here
in Costa Rica what we've been doing is
we've been putting observers on the
boats and we record what we call
relative abundance how many sharks do
you catch per number of hooks that you
put in the water and at least here in
the EEZ of Costa Rica from 1991 to the
year 2000 we have recorded a reduction
of the population of sharks of 60% in
only 19 years it turns out that there
are about 90 boats from Taiwan using
Costa Rica as a base they're coming all
the way from here yeah and they cross
the whole Pacific yeah and right now
they're operating all the way here
basically from the Clipperton islands
which are like right around here yeah
all the way down to the northern coast
of Chile and this is pretty much already
over fished [ __ ] not scary huh it's one
of the most destructive fisheries that
we're seeing now and during this current
century well and added to this
destruction is the way many fishermen
get their fins Randall wants me to see
footage taken by one of his team on a
Costa Rican boat showing the grim
reality of finning
i watch in horror as a scalloped
hammerhead one of the most endangered
shark species has his fin sliced off
while still alive
it's a slow long and drawn-out process
see that one's still alive and wiggling
the pure cruelty of this just imagine
taking a lion in the savannahs of Africa
and cutting its arms off and then just
throwing them out on the savanna to
bleed and to die that would be extremely
cruel the meat of the hammerhead shark
in Costa Rica once they're this size has
no value absolutely if they bring it
back to the port no one will buy it so
that's the that's the incentive to fin
it's without doubt the worst act of
animal cruelty I've ever seen